un pays livré au chaos depuis plus d'un
an
pas d'école pas d'essence ni
d'électricité
une contestation qui ne cesse de grandir
façon à pouvoir viser à ses privilèges
haïti ne vois pas d'issue à la crise et
depuis des mois les réfugiés affluent
vers les pays de la région
arrivée en martinique s'est exilé aspire
à la paix et au travail pour et des
femmes et enfants restés au pays
mais le statut de réfugié politique tant
convoité est très dur à obtenir
you est situation qu'à passer d'un pays
n'ont l'air au v6 sauvé est retombé la
yom ados preview m'adosser ceo d où l
avant dubai al omari au bayoud yosuke
oba qualifie les immigrations qui aiment
béliveau et la limitation est ici posée
là les amis même j'en avais sac à passer
d'un pays à haute et d'outils ville
c'est quoi ce nouveau et mon âme
mouiller avec des papiers pour quatre ou
six mois non renouvelable pas le droit
de travailler et pas toujours un toit
pour dormir au quotidien c'est la peur
des contrôles et de l'expulsion
cette semaine ils ont été nombreux en
ville avec quatre autres essais au
malawi normalement pâte à mâcher ont pas
caché bien normalement donc on sera tous
stressés
en martinique la précarité at on s'est
réfugiés qui continuent d'arriver sont
grandes perspectives d'avenir le lien
avec les familles et même parfois
difficile donc voilà larry côtés de six
airbags année là
vous mêmes devoirs de vaud est qu au cas
où fait éloquent regarder tout ça qu'à
passer d'un rendez vous nature ron même
me paraissent abbas et moi on va en
occaz
non là oui on va regarder à la télé des
bravo car est toute sa capacité
face à ces situations la communauté
haïtienne installé depuis longtemps
ferait presque figure de privilégiés
l'avenir plus qu'incertain en haïti la
plus grande richesse est un titre de
séjour